How do you write that as a lambda? Well, it's like open bracket, close bracket, open paren, auto, ref, space, it, close paren, arrow, decl type auto, open brace, return, start it, semicolon, close brace. So it's something like 30 characters to three is what the difference is. Welcome to ADSB, the podcast, episode 113, recorded on January 15th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Barry Revzin about the potential C++26 pipeline operator, C++ ranges, and more. But our guest today is Barry Rebsin. I'll do the introduction.
How do you write that as a lambda? Well, it's like open bracket, close bracket, open paren, auto, ref, space, it, close paren, arrow, decl type auto, open brace, return, start it, semicolon, close brace. So it's something like 30 characters to three is what the difference is. Welcome to ADSB, the podcast, episode 113, recorded on January 15th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview Barry Revzin about the potential C++26 pipeline operator, C++ ranges, and more. But our guest today is Barry Rebsin. I'll do the introduction.|||你怎么把它写成一个 lambda 表达式呢？差不多就是：方括号、小括号、auto、ref、空格、it、小括号、箭头、decltype auto、大括号、return、解引用 it、分号、大括号。所以大概是 30 个字符对 3 个字符的区别。欢迎来到 ADSB 播客第 113 期，录制于 2023 年 1 月 15 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起采访了巴里·雷夫津（Barry Revzin），讨论了潜在的 C++26 管道操作符、C++ 范围（ranges）等内容。但我们今天的嘉宾是巴里·雷布辛（Barry Rebsin）。我来做个介绍。
Barry is an international keynote speaker. Probably, actually, Bryce, I'm not sure if you know anyone that went faster from giving his first talk to international keynote speaker than Barry, because he gave one talk. And then he gave one talk at C++ now. And then boom, that was it. Next talk, international keynote speaker. That's pretty impressive. It's amazing talk. It compares, I actually don't know the title of it. It compares D, C++, and Rust iterator models. Fantastic talk. I'll put both the C++ now.
Barry is an international keynote speaker. Probably, actually, Bryce, I'm not sure if you know anyone that went faster from giving his first talk to international keynote speaker than Barry, because he gave one talk. And then he gave one talk at C++ now. And then boom, that was it. Next talk, international keynote speaker. That's pretty impressive. It's amazing talk. It compares, I actually don't know the title of it. It compares D, C++, and Rust iterator models. Fantastic talk. I'll put both the C++ now.|||巴里是一位国际主旨发言人。说实话，布莱斯，我不太确定你是否认识比巴里从发表第一次演讲到成为国际主旨发言人速度更快的人，因为他只做了一次演讲，然后他在 C++ Now 上做了一次演讲，接着——砰，就这样了。下一次演讲就是国际主旨发言人。这相当令人印象深刻。这是一个精彩的演讲。它比较了——其实我不知道它的标题——它比较了 D、C++ 和 Rust 的迭代器模型。非常棒的演讲。我会把那个 C++ Now 的……
And I think it was CPPP was the conference that you keynoted at? Yeah, that's right. So there's that. He probably has my favorite C++ blog, although it's not just about C++. But out of all the blogs out there, his is my favorite. So definitely go check out that. And what else can we say? You're one of the most prolific paper writers in contributing to the C++ language and library evolution. I don't know if anybody's done the numbers on it, but for C++23, you probably wrote more papers than anybody else. I don't really count. Yeah,
And I think it was CPPP was the conference that you keynoted at? Yeah, that's right. So there's that. He probably has my favorite C++ blog, although it's not just about C++. But out of all the blogs out there, his is my favorite. So definitely go check out that. And what else can we say? You're one of the most prolific paper writers in contributing to the C++ language and library evolution. I don't know if anybody's done the numbers on it, but for C++23, you probably wrote more papers than anybody else. I don't really count. Yeah,|||我想你在上面做主旨演讲的会议是 CPPP 吧？是的，没错。所以就是那个。他可能拥有我最喜欢的 C++ 博客，尽管它不只是关于 C++ 的。但在所有的博客中，我最喜欢他的。所以一定要去看看。我们还能说什么呢？你是为 C++ 语言和库的演进而贡献最多产的论文撰写者之一。我不知道有没有人统计过，但对于 C++23，你写的论文可能比其他任何人都要多。我其实没怎么统计过。是的，
it's probably, uh, I'm well, yeah, we'll put it out. We'll throw it out there to the listeners. I'm sure there's someone keeping, keeping stats.
it's probably, uh, I'm well, yeah, we'll put it out. We'll throw it out there to the listeners. I'm sure there's someone keeping, keeping stats.|||可能吧，呃，我，好吧，我们会把它放出来。我们会向听众抛出这个问题。我确信有人在做统计。
Let us know where Barry ranks. If he's not number one, he's probably in the top couple because there's a ton of papers that you've written, not just for the C plus plus 23 cycle, but going back. Yeah. And I'm not sure what else should we say? Should we let you
Let us know where Barry ranks. If he's not number one, he's probably in the top couple because there's a ton of papers that you've written, not just for the C plus plus 23 cycle, but going back. Yeah. And I'm not sure what else should we say? Should we let you|||让我们知道巴里的排名。如果他不是第一，他也可能在前几名，因为你写了大量的论文，不仅是为了 C++23 周期，还有以前的。是的。我不确定我们还应该说些什么？我们应该让你……
introduce the things that we haven't said? I'm not sure if you want to say where you work. Some people do, some people don't. Sure. So I work at Jump Trading in Chicago, which is a trading firm that does a little bit of everything. We trade everything, all asset classes, all time zones, all products. Very cool place to be. I've been there for eight and a half years. It's a pretty nice place. Outside of the C++ world, I guess I'm very big into swimming, which is something that a lot of people don't know about me. and it is something that if you see my tweets they're kind of divided into two categories of like random c++ things and whatever's going on in the swimming
introduce the things that we haven't said? I'm not sure if you want to say where you work. Some people do, some people don't. Sure. So I work at Jump Trading in Chicago, which is a trading firm that does a little bit of everything. We trade everything, all asset classes, all time zones, all products. Very cool place to be. I've been there for eight and a half years. It's a pretty nice place. Outside of the C++ world, I guess I'm very big into swimming, which is something that a lot of people don't know about me. and it is something that if you see my tweets they're kind of divided into two categories of like random c++ things and whatever's going on in the swimming|||来介绍一下我们还没说过的事情吗？我不确定你是否想透露你在哪里工作。有些人愿意，有些人则不然。当然。我在芝加哥的 Jump Trading 工作，这是一家涉猎广泛的贸易公司。我们交易所有东西，所有资产类别、所有时区、所有产品。这是一个非常酷的地方。我在那里工作了八年半。这是一个相当不错的地方。在 C++ 世界之外，我想我非常喜欢游泳，这是很多人不知道关于我的一点。而且如果你看到我的推特，它们基本上分为两类：随机的 C++ 事情和游泳界发生的事情……
world um briefly there was this uh professional swim league called the isl i'm hoping it comes back but we'll see if i not um and i was involved in that which is which is a ton of fun um for for a fan yeah do you run the swim slam i know i've seen swim slam is that something separate that uh i think if you go if you youtube your name you'll get your two c++ talks and then you'll get some swimming related things uh yeah so sometimes it's like the premier swimming media organization um if you if you want to know swimming news that's definitely like the place you want to go um it started i don't know maybe 2012 2011 somewhere around there um and i i contribute to it periodically i write like random data articles i run numbers for them or a bunch of
world um briefly there was this uh professional swim league called the isl i'm hoping it comes back but we'll see if i not um and i was involved in that which is which is a ton of fun um for for a fan yeah do you run the swim slam i know i've seen swim slam is that something separate that uh i think if you go if you youtube your name you'll get your two c++ talks and then you'll get some swimming related things uh yeah so sometimes it's like the premier swimming media organization um if you if you want to know swimming news that's definitely like the place you want to go um it started i don't know maybe 2012 2011 somewhere around there um and i i contribute to it periodically i write like random data articles i run numbers for them or a bunch of|||呃，简而言之，曾经有一个叫做 ISL 的职业游泳联盟，我希望它能回归，但我们会看看是否会这样。呃，我曾参与其中，对于一个粉丝来说，这真的非常有意思。是的，你经营 Swim Slam 吗？我知道我见过 Swim Slam，那是独立于……呃，我想如果你在 YouTube 上搜索你的名字，你会得到你的两个 C++ 演讲，然后你会得到一些与游泳相关的东西。呃，是的，所以有时它就像是顶级的游泳媒体机构，呃，如果你想了解游泳新闻，那绝对是你想去的地方。它开始于，我不知道，可能是 2012 年、2011 年左右，呃，我定期为它贡献内容，比如写一些随机的数据文章，为他们运行数据或者做一堆……
stuff uh definitely definitely didn't found it or own it or anything like that i just i just contribute periodically okay just a platform that you contribute to. And also too. So were you, uh, did you, I think you told me this, you swim, you used to swim. Um, but now you don't swim as much and you run or do you do both now? Or are you primarily a runner? Cause I'm not sure if you've listened to the most recent episode, but Bryce is thinking about becoming a runner. And I know that you at least have been going on runs cause I've seen you tweet stuff about it over the past year or so. Yeah, definitely.
stuff uh definitely definitely didn't found it or own it or anything like that i just i just contribute periodically okay just a platform that you contribute to. And also too. So were you, uh, did you, I think you told me this, you swim, you used to swim. Um, but now you don't swim as much and you run or do you do both now? Or are you primarily a runner? Cause I'm not sure if you've listened to the most recent episode, but Bryce is thinking about becoming a runner. And I know that you at least have been going on runs cause I've seen you tweet stuff about it over the past year or so. Yeah, definitely.|||东西。呃，绝对、绝对不是我创立的或拥有的或诸如此类的，我只是定期贡献内容。好的，这只是一个你贡献内容的平台。还有。那么你以前，呃，我想你告诉过我这个，你游泳，你过去常游泳。呃，但现在你游得少了，你在跑步，还是你现在两样都做？或者你主要是一个跑步者？因为我不知道你有没有听最新的一期节目，但布莱斯正考虑成为一名跑步者。而且我知道你至少一直在跑步，因为我在过去一年左右看到你发推特提到过。是的，绝对的。
Definitely run and swim. I'm much better at swimming than running. But it's obviously a lot easier to run because you just like put on a pair of shoes and just go. You don't need to like plan pool time and get there. Actually, that was one of the really nice things about the Kona meeting is that it's just on the ocean. So I don't have to plan to go swim. I just walk out into the ocean and go and I'm already there, which is super nice. During that meeting every day at lunch I would just go swim along with Michael Park
Definitely run and swim. I'm much better at swimming than running. But it's obviously a lot easier to run because you just like put on a pair of shoes and just go. You don't need to like plan pool time and get there. Actually, that was one of the really nice things about the Kona meeting is that it's just on the ocean. So I don't have to plan to go swim. I just walk out into the ocean and go and I'm already there, which is super nice. During that meeting every day at lunch I would just go swim along with Michael Park|||绝对是又跑又游。我擅长游泳胜过跑步。但跑步明显容易得多，因为你只需穿上一双鞋就可以出发了。你不需要计划泳池时间并赶到那里。事实上，科纳（Kona）会议非常棒的一点就在于它直接靠海。所以我不需要计划去游泳。我只要走到海里就可以开始游了，这超级棒。在那次会议期间，每天午餐时我都会和迈克尔·帕克（Michael Park）一起去游泳……
and Matush. It was super nice. I could see why people like Hawaii. Oh yeah. I don't recall where I saw a photo. It might have been on twitter but there was a photo of you michael park and was it matush as well like there's a few of you also i think you were in the water uh and i was like damn that looks quite nice it was it was awesome because it's it's like swimming except you're in the ocean and there's you know fish um on one of the days i nearly ran into a sea turtle uh which is yeah i'm just like i'm kind of you know i'm doing my thing and like there's like i i see this blob out of the days, I nearly ran into a sea turtle. What? Yeah, I'm just like, I'm kind of, you know, I'm doing my thing. And like, there's like, I see this blob out of the corner of my eye.
and Matush. It was super nice. I could see why people like Hawaii. Oh yeah. I don't recall where I saw a photo. It might have been on twitter but there was a photo of you michael park and was it matush as well like there's a few of you also i think you were in the water uh and i was like damn that looks quite nice it was it was awesome because it's it's like swimming except you're in the ocean and there's you know fish um on one of the days i nearly ran into a sea turtle uh which is yeah i'm just like i'm kind of you know i'm doing my thing and like there's like i see this blob out of the days, I nearly ran into a sea turtle. What? Yeah, I'm just like, I'm kind of, you know, I'm doing my thing. And like, there's like, I see this blob out of the corner of my eye.|||还有马图什（Matush）。这真是太棒了。我能理解为什么人们喜欢夏威夷。哦，是的。我不记得在哪里看到一张照片了。可能是在推特上，有一张你、迈克尔·帕克，还有马图什的照片——好像有几个人，我想你们都在水里，呃，当时我就想：天哪，看起来真不错。这太棒了，因为这就像游泳，只是你在海洋里，你知道有鱼。呃，在其中一天，我差点撞上一只海龟，呃，就是，是的，我当时就像，我有点，你知道，我在做我自己的事情，然后，就像，我看到眼角余光里有一个大团块……天哪，我差点撞上一只海龟。什么？是的，我当时就像，我有点，你知道，我在做我自己的事情。然后，就像，我看到眼角余光里有一个大团块。
And I was like, whoa, what was that? And it's like a turtle. So I'm just like start following around for a few minutes. Wow. That's awesome. I thought usually the sea turtles are pretty, pretty timid. Like they don't get too close. No, they're actually, they're pretty like, they don't, they don't really give a about you. They really,
And I was like, whoa, what was that? And it's like a turtle. So I'm just like start following around for a few minutes. Wow. That's awesome. I thought usually the sea turtles are pretty, pretty timid. Like they don't get too close. No, they're actually, they're pretty like, they don't, they don't really give a about you. They really,|||然后我想：哇，那是什么？结果是一只海龟。所以我开始跟着它游了几分钟。哇。太棒了。我以为通常海龟都非常、非常胆小。比如它们不会靠得太近。不，实际上它们相当……它们真的不在乎你。它们真的……
yeah. Like if you're at some of the beaches in, uh, in Kona, um, and like, they think that there's some food like near and area where they are, they'll just come on up. Really? I thought, I guess my impression of that is that I've only been to Hawaii once, but when I did go, I went, what do you call it, snorkeling? And they told us to like give the turtles a lot of space. Yeah, so, and it's actually state law that you're supposed to give them like a good, you know, I don't know, 20 feet or so. You're supposed to sort of stay away from them. I don't know why that is.
yeah. Like if you're at some of the beaches in, uh, in Kona, and like, they think that there's some food like near an area where they are, they'll just come on up. Really? I thought, I guess my impression of that is that I've only been to Hawaii once, but when I did go, I went, what do you call it, snorkeling? And they told us to like give the turtles a lot of space. Yeah, so, and it's actually state law that you're supposed to give them like a good, you know, I don't know, 20 feet or so. You're supposed to sort of stay away from them. I don't know why that is.|||是的。比如如果你在呃科纳的一些海滩上，如果它们觉得它们所在的区域附近有食物，它们就会直接游过来。真的吗？我想，我对那里的印象是——我只去过夏威夷一次，但当我真的去的时候，我去进行了——你们叫什么来着，浮潜？他们告诉我们要给海龟留出很多空间。是的，所以，实际上州法律规定你应该给它们留出相当好的距离，你知道，我不知道，大概 20 英尺左右。你应该离它们远一点。我不知道为什么会这样。
I don't know if it's that like it's really easy for humans to to harm them but i i think it's that like they don't want them to like get too used to um uh like being around humans and i think that they also can like give you a pretty nasty bite but i do know that it's like a it's like a state law well we got to cut this out then because clearly Barry was breaking state laws. You're lucky you didn't get arrested. I did not touch it. I don't think it really counts if you're just like swimming around and like the sea turtle just like – Listen, officer.
I don't know if it's that like it's really easy for humans to to harm them but i i think it's that like they don't want them to like get too used to um uh like being around humans and i think that they also can like give you a pretty nasty bite but i do know that it's like a it's like a state law well we got to cut this out then because clearly Barry was breaking state laws. You're lucky you didn't get arrested. I did not touch it. I don't think it really counts if you're just like swimming around and like the sea turtle just like – Listen, officer.|||我不知道是因为人类很容易伤害它们，还是因为——我认为它们不希望海龟太习惯于呃在人类身边，而且我认为它们也能咬出很厉害的伤口。但我确实知道这是一条州法律。好吧，那我们得把这段剪掉了，因为显然巴里违反了州法律。你很幸运没有被捕。我没有碰它。我不认为如果你只是在四处游动而海龟只是——听着，警官。
He approached me. I just don't think – I don't think that's – I don't think Barry's going to get in trouble for that. Well, we apologize if the C++ community loses a luminary figure, an international keynote speaker, because we— Barry can still write papers. And, you know, the jails in Hawaii, not to offend the great state of Hawaii, but, you know, the airports in Hawaii are, like, all outside. So I'm sure the jails in Hawaii probably have like a nice pool. All right. Well, stay tuned, folks. We'll give you live updates as to Barry's incarceration status.
He approached me. I just don't think – I don't think that's – I don't think Barry's going to get in trouble for that. Well, we apologize if the C++ community loses a luminary figure, an international keynote speaker, because we— Barry can still write papers. And, you know, the jails in Hawaii, not to offend the great state of Hawaii, but, you know, the airports in Hawaii are, like, all outside. So I'm sure the jails in Hawaii probably have like a nice pool. All right. Well, stay tuned, folks. We'll give you live updates as to Barry's incarceration status.|||是他接近我的。我只是觉得——我不认为那是——我不认为巴里会因此惹上麻烦。好吧，如果 C++ 社区失去了一位泰斗级人物、一位国际主旨发言人，我们深表歉意，因为我们——巴里仍然可以写论文。而且，你知道，夏威夷的监狱——无意冒犯伟大的夏威夷州，但你知道，夏威夷的机场就像都在露天一样。所以我确信夏威夷的监狱里可能有一个不错的游泳池。好的。好吧，各位请继续关注。我们将为您提供关于巴里入狱状态的实时更新。
Not where I thought this podcast was going. Yeah. Well, you know. Yeah. Nobody ever knows what this podcast is. Chaos with sprinkles of information. That's our tagline that someone on Reddit gave us. Well, speaking of chaos, I mean, we can – I'm not sure if you had plans of what you want to talk
Not where I thought this podcast was going. Yeah. Well, you know. Yeah. Nobody ever knows what this podcast is. Chaos with sprinkles of information. That's our tagline that someone on Reddit gave us. Well, speaking of chaos, I mean, we can – I'm not sure if you had plans of what you want to talk|||这不是我以为这个播客会走向的方向。是的。嗯，你知道的。是的。没有人知道这个播客到底是什么。夹杂着零星信息的混乱。这是 Reddit 上有人给我们的标语。好吧，说到混乱，我是说，我们可以——我不确定你对想谈论的内容有没有什么计划……
about, Barry. Definitely at the top of my list is your pipeline operator papers, because it's probably for C++26 the number one thing that I'm excited for, given that we have now a bunch of ranges, adapters in C++23, specifically a bunch that don't work with the pipe operator, which we can talk about in a sec. But before we launch into that paper, and then also the error propagation paper, because I want to talk about that one as well. Is there anything you want to, because you've written so many papers, obviously active in C++, anything you want to start off or things you want to say. Oh, we should also mention you were a guest on CppCast, which is back, but you were a
about, Barry. Definitely at the top of my list is your pipeline operator papers, because it's probably for C++26 the number one thing that I'm excited for, given that we have now a bunch of ranges, adapters in C++23, specifically a bunch that don't work with the pipe operator, which we can talk about in a sec. But before we launch into that paper, and then also the error propagation paper, because I want to talk about that one as well. Is there anything you want to, because you've written so many papers, obviously active in C++, anything you want to start off or things you want to say. We should also mention you were a guest on CppCast, which is back, but you were a|||巴里。绝对排在我清单首位的是你的管道操作符论文，因为对于 C++26 来说，这可能是我最期待的第一件事，鉴于我们在 C++23 中现在有一堆范围适配器，特别是有一堆不能与管道操作符一起工作的适配器，我们一会儿可以谈谈这个。但在我们深入探讨那篇论文以及错误传播论文之前——因为我也想聊聊那篇——有什么你想……因为你写了那么多的论文，显然在 C++ 中非常活跃，有什么你想作为开场白或想说的话吗？我们还应该提到你曾是 CppCast 的嘉宾——该节目现在回归了——但你曾是……
guest back before it took a hiatus. We'll put that link in the show notes where I think you talk about, I think pipes is in the title of that episode. Yeah, I was talking about, yeah, I remember talking about pipeline there too. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we can talk about whatever. I have no particular agenda.
guest back before it took a hiatus. We'll put that link in the show notes where I think you talk about, I think pipes is in the title of that episode. Yeah, I was talking about, yeah, I remember talking about pipeline there too. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we can talk about whatever. I have no particular agenda.|||在它暂停更新之前的嘉宾。我们会把那个链接放在节目笔记中，我想你在那里谈论过——我想那期节目的标题里有 pipes。是的，我谈到了，是的，我记得我也在那里谈论过管道。是的。是的。我的意思是，我们可以谈论任何事情。我没有什么特别的议程。
All righty. So, I mean, Bryce, you can go Google this paper. Have you read the paper, Bryce? Probably the pipeline. Well, so there's two papers and we'll get Barry to give us a little background both, but there's 2011, which was the first paper. And I believe that was published in 2020. I'm going to say, but that could be wrong about that. But there's more recently a paper, what's the number? 2672. Looks like there's only R0 at the moment. And that came out in October of 2022. That paper is entitled Exploring the Design Space for a Pipeline Operator, which it starts off by sort of referencing the... Yeah, I've only read the first one. Yeah, it starts off referencing 2011, but then talks about the fact that there's a number of
All righty. So, I mean, Bryce, you can go Google this paper. Have you read the paper, Bryce? Probably the pipeline. Well, so there's two papers and we'll get Barry to give us a little background both, but there's 2011, which was the first paper. And I believe that was published in 2020. I'm going to say, but that could be wrong about that. But there's more recently a paper, what's the number? 2672. Looks like there's only R0 at the moment. And that came out in October of 2022. That paper is entitled Exploring the Design Space for a Pipeline Operator, which it starts off by sort of referencing the... Yeah, I've only read the first one. Yeah, it starts off referencing 2011, but then talks about the fact that there's a number of|||好的。那么，我的意思是，布莱斯，你可以去谷歌搜索这篇论文。你读过这篇论文吗，布莱斯？大概是管道那篇。嗯，所以有两篇论文，我们会请巴里为我们介绍这两篇的背景，其中有一篇是 2011，这是第一篇。我相信那是 2020 年发表的，我这么说，但这也可能不对。不过最近还有一篇论文，编号是多少？2672。看起来目前只有 R0 版本。那是 2022 年 10 月发布的。那篇论文题为《探索管道操作符的设计空间》（Exploring the Design Space for a Pipeline Operator），它一开始通过引用……是的，我只读了第一篇。是的，它一开始引用了 2011，但随后讨论了这样一个事实：存在着许多……
different models. And anyways, I'll throw it over to you, Barry. You can give us an overview of the it starts off referencing 2011, but then talks about the fact that there's a number of different models. And anyways, I'll throw it over to you, Barry, you can give us an overview of the paper and in however much detail you want. And then we can talk about, is it going to show up in C++26? Are people for it, against it, et cetera, over to you. Yeah. So, so that second one is, I think the right way to describe that second paper is abusively long, which is how Zach Lane described it. And I ranges works is it has certain kinds of algorithms are things that you can pipe into. So instead of writing f of x, you can write x pipe f. And those algorithms are all the range adapters. So you can have some range pipe into views transform, piped into views filter, piped into views join um and that gives you this nice linear flow um of of the work that's being done um which which makes it like much nicer to to read um since a lot of these things once you get
different models. And anyways, I'll throw it over to you, Barry. You can give us an overview of the it starts off referencing 2011, but then talks about the fact that there's a number of different models. And anyways, I'll throw it over to you, Barry, you can give us an overview of the paper and in however much detail you want. And then we can talk about, is it going to show up in C++26? Are people for it, against it, et cetera, over to you. Yeah. So, so that second one is, I think the right way to describe that second paper is abusively long, which is how Zach Lane described it. And I ranges works is it has certain kinds of algorithms are things that you can pipe into. So instead of writing f of x, you can write x pipe f. And those algorithms are all the range adapters. So you can have some range pipe into views transform, piped into views filter, piped into views join um and that gives you this nice linear flow um of of the work that's being done um which which makes it like much nicer to to read um since a lot of these things once you get|||不同的模型。不管怎样，我把话筒交给你，巴里。你可以给我们概述一下——它一开始引用了 2011，但随后谈到了有许多不同的模型。不管怎样，我把话筒交给你，巴里，你可以用你想要的任何详细程度给我们概述一下这篇论文。然后我们可以讨论：它会出现在 C++26 中吗？人们是赞成还是反对，等等，交给你了。是的。所以，第二篇论文，我认为描述它的正确方式是“长得离谱”，扎克·莱恩（Zach Lane）就是这么形容它的。我的范围库的工作方式是，它让某些类型的算法可以通过管道输入。所以与其写 f(x)，你还可以写 x pipe f。这些算法全都是范围适配器。所以你可以让某个范围通过管道输入到 views transform，通过管道输入到 views filter，通过管道输入到 views join，呃，这为你正在做的工作提供了一种很好的线性流，呃，这使得它读起来好得多，因为一旦你……
to all a lot of the adapters take a second argument in addition to the range and trying to write that um as just function calls tends to be very tedious because you have to read it all inside out, which is, you know, I find it a bit hard to read. But that syntax is really nice, but it has two problems. One is that it requires some library machinery to implement, and that library machinery doesn't lend itself very well to providing good diagnostics. So if you write something like use transform r comma f and f isn't a valid function for that range, you're much likely to
to all a lot of the adapters take a second argument in addition to the range and trying to write that       as just function calls tends to be very tedious because you have to read it all inside out, which is, you know, I find it a bit hard to read. But that syntax is really nice, but it has two problems. One is that it requires some library machinery to implement, and that library machinery doesn't lend itself very well to providing good diagnostics. So if you write something like use transform r comma f and f isn't a valid function for that range, you're much likely to|||适配器除了范围之外还需要第二个参数，而试图仅仅作为函数调用来编写它往往非常繁琐，因为你必须由内向外地阅读所有这些，你知道的，我发现这有点难以阅读。但这种语法真的很好，不过它有两个问题。一个是它需要一些库机制来实现，而这些库机制并不利于提供良好的诊断信息。所以如果你写类似 use transform r comma f 的代码，而 f 不是该范围的有效函数，你很有可能会……
get an error that says something like that than if you do r piped into transform of f. And this is because in the, in the first case, you're actually trying to call the thing. And in the second case, you're trying to call some pipe operator that ends up being removed from consideration. So you'll tend to get errors for like other pipe operators that aren't relevant.
get an error that says something like that than if you do r piped into transform of f. And this is because in the, in the first case, you're actually trying to call the thing. And in the second case, you're trying to call some pipe operator that ends up being removed from consideration. So you'll tend to get errors for like other pipe operators that aren't relevant.|||得到一个类似那样的错误，这比你使用 r piped into transform of f 时要多得多。这是因为在第一种情况下，你实际上是在试图调用那个东西。而在第二种情况下，你是在试图调用某个最终被排除在外的管道操作符。所以你往往会得到针对其他不相关的管道操作符的错误。
So that's not the best. The other problem is that there's a bunch of other algorithms that you can't pipe them to. So like all the, all the things that like are typically referred to as algorithms, like all this stuff in std ranges. Cause typically what you do is you build up your pipeline and then you consume it somehow,
So that's not the best. The other problem is that there's a bunch of other algorithms that you can't pipe them to. So like all the, all the things that like are typically referred to as algorithms, like all this stuff in std ranges. Cause typically what you do is you build up your pipeline and then you consume it somehow,|||所以这并不是最好的。另一个问题是，还有一堆其他的算法，你无法将它们通过管道输入。就像所有那些通常被称为算法的东西，比如 std ranges 中的所有这些东西。因为通常你所做的，是构建你的管道，然后以某种方式消费它，
right? You, you either just iterate over it with a for loop or you pass it into like, now we're going to have ranges two and C++ 23 to like turn it into a collection. Or you, you just use something like, I don't know, ranges min or ranges or you you just use something like i don't know ranges
right? You, you either just iterate over it with a for loop or you pass it into like, now we're going to have ranges two and C++ 23 to like turn it into a collection. Or you, you just use something like, I don't know, ranges min or ranges or you you just use something like i don't know ranges|||对吧？你，要么只是用一个 for 循环迭代它，要么把它传给——比如现在我们在 C++23 中将拥有 ranges two 来把它变成一个集合。或者你，你只是用类似于，我不知道，ranges min 或 ranges，或者你只是用类似于，我不知道，ranges……
min or ranges max or ranges fold or something like you you consume it with some kind of algorithm um but you can't pipe into those algorithms because we just decided that that wasn't that wasn't a thing so you you kind of go back to this inside out style so you have to write like ranges min and then your pipeline instead of just doing R pipe to transform pipe to min, which is something that you can write in other languages. Wasn't it quite intentional that we made things like ranges fold, like the algorithms not pipeable because they weren't lazy? So, yeah, it's intentional that the adapters and then so in range c3 also has actions which which aren't lazy they are they are eager as well those are pipeable um but but not the algorithms i don't i don't really think of that distinction as especially meaningful um
min or ranges max or ranges fold or something like you you consume it with some kind of algorithm um but you can't pipe into those algorithms because we just decided that that wasn't that wasn't a thing so you you kind of go back to this inside out style so you have to write like ranges min and then your pipeline instead of just doing R pipe to transform pipe to min, which is something that you can write in other languages. Wasn't it quite intentional that we made things like ranges fold, like the algorithms not pipeable because they weren't lazy? So, yeah, it's intentional that the adapters and then so in range c3 also has actions which which aren't lazy they are they are eager as well those are pipeable um but but not the algorithms i don't i don't really think of that distinction as especially meaningful um|||min 或 ranges max 或 ranges fold 或类似的东西，比如你用某种算法来消费它，呃，但你不能将管道输入到这些算法中，因为我们刚刚决定那不是——那不是一回事，所以你有点回到了这种由内向外的风格，以至于你必须写成像 ranges min 然后是你的管道，而不是仅仅写 R pipe to transform pipe to min，这是你在其他语言中可以写的东西。我们把像 ranges fold 这样的算法（因为它们不是惰性的）设计成不可通过管道输入的，这难道不是很有意的吗？所以，是的，适配器是有意为之的，然后所以在 range-v3 中也有 actions，它们也不是惰性的，它们也是急切求值的（eager），那些是可以管道输入的，呃，但算法则不行，我——我并不真的认为这种区别有什么特别的意义，呃……
piping i think of as then why didn't we make the uh the algorithms well part of it is just like that's that's just like more work that you have to do. There's also this issue of not everything can be easily made pipeable because you don't always have this clear way of determining whether your call is a full function call or a partial function call. So some of the easy examples with range adapters are things like Zip and Concat, where you can't differentiate between which kind of call you're making because well they couldn't just take an arbitrary amount of ranges um so zip zip a is a is a valid thing and you you have no way of knowing at the call side of which which uh that you meant it to be like a partial invocation this is also a problem with
piping i think of as then why didn't we make the uh the algorithms well part of it is just like that's that's just like more work that you have to do. There's also this issue of not everything can be easily made pipeable because you don't always have this clear way of determining whether your call is a full function call or a partial function call. So some of the easy examples with range adapters are things like Zip and Concat, where you can't differentiate between which kind of call you're making because well they couldn't just take an arbitrary amount of ranges um so zip zip a is a is a valid thing and you you have no way of knowing at the call side of which which uh that you meant it to be like a partial invocation this is also a problem with|||管道输入，我认为——那么为什么我们不把呃算法……嗯，部分原因只是，这就像——这只是你需要做的更多工作。还有一个问题是，并非所有东西都能轻易地做成可管道输入的，因为你并不总是有这种清晰的方法来确定你的调用是完全函数调用还是部分函数调用。所以范围适配器的一些简单例子是像 Zip 和 Concat 这样的东西，在这些例子中，你无法区分你正在进行哪种调用，因为，嗯，它们不能只接受任意数量的范围，呃，所以 zip(a) 是一个有效的东西，而你在调用点无法知道你意图让它成为像部分调用（partial invocation）那样的东西。这也是……
things from like the sender's proposal like things like when all anything that's like very addict like that, it, you can't really make it payable. Yeah. So that's something I noticed when I, I'm not sure if you saw that tweet, but I tweeted a couple of weeks ago that I realized GCC trunk, AKA what will be 13 when they release it has implemented all the range adapters from C++23. And while I was, if you actually look at the code example, it's zip transform, zip adjacent, I think as well. And then the pairwise specializations, none of those are, at least in the GCC implementation, and I didn't go take a look at the standard pipeable. Yeah, they're not, they're not, they're not even specified. That's how they're designed. So the transforms have this other problem in that the first argument is the function.
things from like the sender's proposal like things like when all anything that's like very addict like that, it, you can't really make it payable. Yeah. So that some things I noticed when I, I'm not sure if you saw that tweet, but I tweeted a couple of weeks ago that I realized GCC trunk, AKA what will be 13 when they release it has implemented all the range adapters from C++23. And while I was, if you actually look at the code example, it's zip transform, zip adjacent, I think as well. And then the pairwise specializations, none of those are, at least in the GCC implementation, and I didn't go take a look at the standard pipeable. Yeah, they're not, they're not, they're not even specified. That's how they're designed. So the transforms have this other problem in that the first argument is the function.|||诸如来自 sender 提案之类的事情的问题，比如 when all 任何非常具有可变参数（variadic）特性的东西，它，你真的无法让它成为可管道输入的。是的。所以这是我在——我不确定你是否看到了那条推特，但我几周前发了一条推特，说我意识到 GCC trunk（也就是他们发布时的 13 版本）已经实现了来自 C++23 的所有范围适配器。而当我在——如果你实际查看代码示例，它是 zip transform，还有 zip adjacent，我想也是。然后是 pairwise 特化，这些都不是，至少在 GCC 的实现中是这样，而且我没有去看标准的可管道性。是的，它们不是，它们甚至都没有被指定。它们就是这样设计的。所以 transforms 还有另一个问题，即第一个参数是函数。
So if they're pipable, that's not really like the model of piping because we pipe the first argument and you'd want to pipe the second. So this is basically the genesis of this paper is that we have this one problem that getting the piping to work requires library machinery that's just like tedious to implement at best and isn't great for diagnostics at worst and then there's all this other stuff that we want to make pipeable but doing so is possible but but just tedious um and with like we could do it for the standard library algorithms but that doesn't help user algorithms that they might want to write so this is like just like more tedious for everyone. So it would be nice to have a way of getting the syntactic benefits of this without all
So if they're pipable, that's not really like the model of piping because we pipe the first argument and you'd want to pipe the second. So this is basically the genesis of this paper is that we have this one problem that getting the piping to work requires library machinery that's just like tedious to implement at best and isn't great for diagnostics at worst and then there's all this other stuff that we want to make pipeable but doing so is possible but but just tedious um and with like we could do it for the standard library algorithms but that doesn't help user algorithms that they might want to write so this is like just like more tedious for everyone. So it would be nice to have a way of getting the syntactic benefits of this without all|||所以如果它们是可管道输入的，那其实就不太符合管道的模型，因为我们是通过管道输入第一个参数，而你却希望通过管道输入第二个。所以这基本上就是这篇论文的起源：我们有一个问题，即让管道正常工作需要库机制，充其量实现起来很繁琐，最坏的情况下对诊断也不友好；然后还有所有其他我们想要使其可管道化的东西，这样做是可能的，但只是很繁琐，呃，而且虽然我们可以为标准库算法这样做，但这无助于用户可能想要编写的自定义算法，所以这就像对每个人来说都更繁琐。因此，如果有一种方法可以在没有所有……
of the complexity and all the machinery. So this is where the pipeline idea was born. Well, I should say born. We didn't invent this concept. This concept exists in other languages before us. And I say us because colby pike um better known as vector pool um is is the first person that i saw pushing this idea so he's he's my co-author on that initial
of the complexity and all the machinery. So this is where the pipeline idea was born. Well, I should say born. We didn't invent this concept. This concept exists in other languages before us. And I say us because colby pike um better known as vector pool um is is the first person that i saw pushing this idea so he's he's my co-author on that initial|||复杂性和所有机制的情况下获得这种语法的益处，那就太好了。这就是管道想法诞生的背景。嗯，我应该说诞生。我们并没有发明这个概念。在我们之前，这个概念就已经存在于其他语言中了。我说“我们”，是因为 Colby Pike（更为人所知的名字是 vector_pool）呃是我看到的第一个推动这个想法的人，所以他是——他是那篇最初论文的我的合著者……
paper um and so the first revision of the paper the first thing that we tried to do was just define the simplest model, which is that X pipeline F of Y evaluates as F of X comma Y. We take the argument on the left-hand side and a call expression on the right-hand side, and that is evaluated as the left-hand argument as the first argument. It gets inserted into the first slide of the call. So there's no intermediate expression. F of Y is never evaluated. It doesn't even have to be valid. It's just a single thing. So this is a fairly simple thing to explain.
paper um and so the first revision of the paper the first thing that we tried to do was just define the simplest model, which is that X pipeline F of Y evaluates as F of X comma Y. We take the argument on the left-hand side and a call expression on the right-hand side, and that is evaluated as the left-hand argument as the first argument. It gets inserted into the first slide of the call. So there's no intermediate expression. F of Y is never evaluated. It doesn't even have to be valid. It's just a single thing. So this is a fairly simple thing to explain.|||论文，呃，所以论文的第一个修订版，我们尝试做的第一件事就是定义最简单的模型，即 X pipeline F of Y 求值为 F of X comma Y。我们取左侧的参数和右侧的调用表达式，这被求值为将左侧参数作为第一个参数。它被插入到调用的第一个位置。所以没有中间表达式。F of Y 永远不会被求值。它甚至不需要是有效的。它只是一个单一的东西。所以这是一个相当容易解释的事情。
It behaves a lot like member function call, if you think about it. Like x dot f of y, what that does is it shifts x over to be the first argument. And especially now with deducing this, it really does behave like that. Like we're moving this parameter around and making one function call.
It behaves a lot like member function call, if you think about it. Like x dot f of y, what that does is it shifts x over to be the first argument. And especially now with deducing this, it really does behave like that. Like we're moving this parameter around and making one function call.|||如果你仔细想想，它的行为很像成员函数调用。比如 x.f(y)，它的作用是将 x 移位成为第一个参数。特别是现在有了 deducing this（显式对象参数推导），它的行为确实如此。就像我们在移动这个参数并进行一次函数调用一样。
So that was kind of the initial design that we had. And this was the 2011? Yeah, so that was the R0. And so it turns out, as with a lot of things that are seemingly simple, there's a lot of interesting things to think about in this space. One ends up being, well, what's the precedence of this thing? And it kind of turns into like a surprisingly weird thing to consider. So one example might be, so if, okay, so x pipeline to f of y validates as f of x comma y, what does like f pipeline to f open paren y close paren open paren close paren mean? Which of the two function calls are we moving x into? And the same kind of holds for other kind of like post-script expressions. So you end up kind of wanting to have it to have very high precedence because it behaves a lot like dot.
So that was kind of the initial design that we had. And this was the 2011? Yeah, so that was the R0. And so it turns out, as with a lot of things that are seemingly simple, there's a lot of interesting things to think about in this space. One ends up being, well, what's the precedence of this thing? And it kind of turns into like a surprisingly weird thing to consider. So one example might be, so if, okay, so x pipeline to f of y validates as f of x comma y, what does like f pipeline to f open paren y close paren open paren close paren mean? Which of the two function calls are we moving x into? And the same kind of holds for other kind of like post-script expressions. So you end up kind of wanting to have it to have very high precedence because it behaves a lot like dot.|||所以这差不多是我们最初的设计。这就是那个 2011 吗？是的，所以那是 R0。结果证明，正如许多看似简单的事情一样，在这个领域有很多有趣的事情需要考虑。其中一个最终变成：嗯，这东西的优先级是什么？这有点变成了一件令人惊讶的奇怪事情去考虑。所以一个例子可能是，如果，好吧，如果 x pipeline to f of y 的有效性等同于 f(x, y)，那么像 f pipeline to f(y)() 这样意味着什么？我们将 x 移入这两个函数调用中的哪一个？其他类似后缀表达式的情况也大致如此。所以你最终会希望它的优先级非常高，因为它很像点号（dot）。
So you want it to behave like dot. And there are a lot of kind of interesting things there. But then we kind of started talking about, well, like there's a lot of other interesting things you might want to do with piping. So the zip transform example you brought up, you don't want to pipe into the first argument. You want to pipe into the second, maybe even the third, depending on what you want to do. So wouldn't it give more flexibility if we open up to the user where we're moving this argument into? So like if there's a placeholder that we could pipe into. Well, there's also the case where you might want to pipe it into multiple arguments, right? And that also becomes useful if you,
So you want it to behave like dot. And there are a lot of kind of interesting things there. But then we kind of started talking about, well, like there's a lot of other interesting things you might want to do with piping. So the zip transform example you brought up, you don't want to pipe into the first argument. You want to pipe into the second, maybe even the third, depending on what you want to do. So wouldn't it give more flexibility if we open up to the user where we're moving this argument into? So like if there's a placeholder that we could pipe into. Well, there's also the case where you might want to pipe it into multiple arguments, right? And that also becomes useful if you,|||所以你希望它的行为像点号。那里有很多类似有趣的事情。但随后我们开始讨论，嗯，就像你可能想用管道做很多其他有趣的事情一样。所以你提出的 zip transform 的例子，你不想把管道输入到第一个参数中。你想要输入到第二个，甚至可能是第三个，这取决于你想做什么。因此，如果我们向用户开放我们将这个参数移动到哪里，这难道不会提供更多的灵活性吗？比如如果有一个我们可以通过管道输入的占位符。嗯，还有一种情况是，你可能想要把它通过管道输入到多个参数中，对吧？这也会变得很有用，如果你……
when you want to do like more complex things, like, you know, fork join style models, which you can sort of emulate with some sort of like tuple-like object where, you know, you do something like similar to, similar to like a zip or like a win-all in senders. But then like later in the chain, you want to decompose it into its constituent parts. And maybe you want to call a function
when you want to do like more complex things, like, you know, fork join style models, which you can sort of emulate with some sort of like tuple-like object where, you know, do something like similar to, similar to like a zip or like a win-all in senders. But then like later in the chain, you want to decompose it into its constituent parts. And maybe you want to call a function|||当你想做更复杂的事情时，比如，你知道的，fork-join 风格的模型，你可以用某种类似于元组（tuple-like）的对象来某种程度上模拟它，你知道的，做一些类似于——类似于 zip 或者 senders 中的 when all 的事情。但随后在链条的后面，你想把它分解成它的组成部分。也许你想调用一个函数……
where you want to say like, call this with the first and third argument of this tuple as the two arguments of this function. But without a model that has a placeholder, it's a little tricky to do that cleanly. Yeah, so placeholders are also interesting because arguably they make it more clear what's going on. Like if you see this expression on the right-hand side
where you want to say like, call this with the first and third argument of this tuple as the two arguments of this function. But without a model that has a placeholder, it's a little tricky to do that cleanly. Yeah, so placeholders are also interesting because arguably they make it more clear what's going on. Like if you see this expression on the right-hand side|||在这里你想表达：用这个元组的第一和第三个参数作为这个函数的两个参数来调用它。但是如果没有一个带有占位符的模型，要干净利落地做到这一点就有点棘手了。是的，所以占位符也很有趣，因为可以说它们使正在发生的事情更加清晰。比如如果你在右侧看到这个表达式……
and you see a placeholder, you kind of know that like, okay, well, this is where the argument on the left is going. But then once you get into placeholders, so one of the interesting issues with multiple placeholders is like, okay, well, if the left-hand side is an L value, then having multiple placeholders, okay, well, that's obvious, right? You evaluate the left-hand side once and you just like use it in both places. But if the left-hand side is an R value, well, like what do you actually do with it? You definitely don't want to evaluate it twice because that just seems totally, totally wrong
and you see a placeholder, you kind of know that like, okay, well, this is where the argument on the left is going. But then once you get into placeholders, so one of the interesting issues with multiple placeholders is like, okay, well, if the left-hand side is an L value, then having multiple placeholders, okay, well, that's obvious, right? You evaluate the left-hand side once and you just like use it in both places. But if the left-hand side is an R value, well, like what do you actually do with it? You definitely don't want to evaluate it twice because that just seems totally, totally wrong|||并且你看到了一个占位符，你就会知道：好吧，这就是左侧参数要去的地方。但一旦你进入占位符，多个占位符带来的有趣问题之一就是：好吧，如果左侧是一个左值（Lvalue），那么有多个占位符，好吧，那是显而易见的，对吧？你对左侧求值一次，然后就像在两个地方都使用它一样。但如果左侧是一个右值（Rvalue），嗯，那你实际上该拿它怎么办呢？你绝对不想对它求值两次，因为那看起来完全、完全是错的……
and very surprising. But if you evaluate it once, that just seems totally totally wrong and very surprising um but if you evaluate it once do you like give it as an r value in both places do you like escalate it to be an l value um that's that's kind of hard like i don't know what the right answer for that is so like i think in the in the in the last paper i'm um i suggest escalating it to be an l value like evaluate it once and then treat it as an L value multiple times. Alternatively, make it ill-formed if it's not an L value. Because you can always stick in a function in the middle to turn it into an L value and then pipe that L value twice if that's what you really want. But at least then it's explicit. So this is kind of what I mean
and very surprising. But if you evaluate it once, that just seems totally totally wrong and very surprising um but if you evaluate it once do you like give it as an r value in both places do you like escalate it to be an l value um that's that's hard like i don't know what the right answer for that is so like i think in the in the in the last paper i'm um i suggest escalating it to be an l value like evaluate it once and then treat it as an L value multiple times. Alternatively, make it ill-formed if it's not an L value. Because you can always stick in a function in the middle to turn it into an L value and then pipe that L value twice if that's what you really want. But at least then it's explicit. So this is kind of what I mean|||并且非常令人惊讶。但如果你对它求值一次，那看起来完全、完全是错的，而且非常令人惊讶，呃，但如果你对它求值一次，你是像在两个地方都把它当作右值传递，还是像把它提升为左值？呃，这——这很难，就像我不知道这的正确答案是什么。所以，我想在——在上一篇论文中，我呃建议将其提升为左值，比如求值一次，然后多次将其视为左值。或者，如果它不是左值，则使其成为非良构（ill-formed）的。因为你总是可以在中间插入一个函数将其转换为左值，然后如果这真的是你想要的，再将该左值通过管道输入两次。但至少那样是显式的。所以这差不多就是我的意思……
by like once you start diving into things, there's all these like weird issues that come up. So one is like, okay, like where can you pipe things into? Because one of the things, when you look at it syntactically, you have this expression and then you have pipeline and then you have stuff. So like it really looks like you're always evaluating the left-hand side, right? So you don't necessarily want to allow piping into a location that it wouldn't necessarily be evaluated in. So for instance, like x piped to like y or placeholder, well, you're not always evaluating that expression then. So like if you unconditionally evaluate it but then use it in a context that it has short-circuiting, that's kind of weird.
by like once you start diving into things, there's all these like weird issues that come up. So one is like, okay, like where can you pipe things into? Because one of the things, when you look at it syntactically, you have this expression and then you have pipeline and then you have stuff. So like it really looks like you're always evaluating the left-hand side, right? So you don't necessarily want to allow piping into a location that it wouldn't necessarily be evaluated in. So for instance, like x piped to like y or placeholder, well, you're not always evaluating that expression then. So like if you unconditionally evaluate it but then use it in a context that it has short-circuiting, that's kind of weird.|||当开始深入研究某些事情时，就会出现所有这些奇怪的问题。所以其中一个问题是，好吧，你可以把东西通过管道输入到哪里？因为其中一件事是，从语法上看，你有这个表达式，然后你有 pipeline，然后你有东西。所以看起来你总是在对左侧求值，对吧？因此，你未必想允许将管道输入到一个未必会对其求值的位置。例如，像 x piped to y || placeholder，嗯，那你并非总是在对该表达式求值。所以，如果你无条件地对它求值，但随后在具有短路求值的上下文中使用它，这就有点奇怪了。
And then what if you then use it in an unevaluated context on the right-hand side? You have an expression, then you pipe it into a decl type of that expression. Also, well, it looks like you're evaluating it, but you're not if we think about the expression rewrite. So is that something you want to allow or no? So this is why the paper ends up being abusively long uh because you have to deal with all this stuff um where it gets even more interesting is that like once you have placeholders you can think about like well what does the we have this right hand expression
And then what if you then use it in an unevaluated context on the right-hand side? You have an expression, then you pipe it into a decl type of that expression. Also, well, look like you're evaluating it, but you're not if we think about the expression rewrite. So is that something you want to allow or no? So this is why the paper ends up being abusively long uh because you have to deal with all this stuff um where it gets even more interesting is that like once you have placeholders you can think about like well what does the we have this right hand expression|||然后，如果你随后在右侧的未求值上下文中使用它呢？你有一个表达式，然后你把它通过管道输入到该表达式的 decltype 中。同样，嗯，看起来你是在对它求值，但如果我们考虑表达式重写，你并没有。所以这是你想允许的还是不想允许的？这就是为什么这篇论文最后长得离谱，呃，因为你必须处理所有这些事情，呃，更有趣的是，一旦你有了占位符，你就可以考虑——嗯，我们有这个右侧表达式，它是什么……
that has placeholders in it but like what is how does it behave like if you look at that thing in like if you look at like f open paren let let's say dollars or placeholder, like f open paren, dollar close paren that's kind of like a lambda right? you can kind of think of it as like constructing a lambda with placeholders on the fly and then invoking it
that has placeholders in it but like what is how does it behave like if you look at that thing in like if you look at like f open paren let let's say dollars or placeholder, like f open paren, dollar close paren that's kind of like a lambda right? you can kind of think of it as like constructing a lambda with placeholders on the fly and then invoking it|||其中包含占位符，但它的行为是怎样的？如果你看那个东西，比如说 f($, $) 或者占位符，比如 f( dollar )，那有点像一个 lambda，对吧？你可以把它看作是在动态构造一个带有占位符的 lambda 并调用它。
it's not exactly that and in fact in the old library only boost lambda model that's how you would write a lambda function is you would have these um these like underscore one underscore two underscore three uh placeholders that were these you know magic objects and you could do like underscore one plus three and then that would give you back a lambda that would do take one argument and then that would add three to it and i i still know some people who use that library,
it's not exactly that and in fact in the old library only boost lambda model that's how you would write a lambda function is you would have these um these like underscore one underscore two underscore three placeholders that were these you know magic objects and you could do like underscore one plus three and then that would give you back a lambda that would do take one argument and then that would add three to it and i i still know some people who use that library,|||这并不完全是那样，事实上在旧的纯库 boost lambda 模型中，这就是你编写 lambda 函数的方式：你会拥有这些呃类似 _1、_2、_3 的占位符，它们是那些（你知道的）魔术对象，你可以写像 _1 + 3 的代码，然后它会返回给你一个 lambda，该 lambda 接受一个参数并给它加 3，而我——我仍然认识一些使用该库的人……
even though we have, you know, C++11 lambdas because it's such a, when you're doing something that the library, when you fit into one of the use cases, like, you know, adding up some things that the library is really good at, like it's much more concise to just write your Lambda that way.
even though we have, you5++11 lambdas because it's such a, when you're doing something that the library, when you fit into one of the use cases, like, you know, adding up some things that the library is really good at, like it's much more concise to just write your Lambda that way.|||尽管我们有了 C++11 lambda，因为它是如此地——当你做一些库擅长的事情时，当你契合其中一个用例时，比如，你知道的，把一些东西加起来，库非常擅长这一点，以至于直接那样编写你的 Lambda 要简洁得多。
Yeah, absolutely. And there's actually, there's a new boost library called boost Lambda too, that Peter Demoff wrote a couple of years ago. And it's, I mean, it's, it's fantastic. So when I was implementing zip as part of like, so Tim Song wrote the paper for zip and then I implemented it kind of from spec to make sure that all the wording was right.
Yeah, absolutely. And there's actually, there's a new boost library called boost Lambda too, that Peter Demoff wrote a couple of years ago. And it's, I mean, it's, it's fantastic. So when I was implementing zip as part of like, so Tim Song wrote the paper for zip and then I implemented it kind of from spec to make sure that all the wording was right.|||是的，绝对的。实际上还有一个新的 boost 库叫做 boost Lambda 2，是彼得·德莫夫（Peter Demoff）几年前写的。而且它，我的意思是，它太棒了。所以当我实现 zip 作为一部分时——比如，蒂姆·宋（Tim Song）写了 zip 的论文，然后我根据规范实现了它，以确保所有的措辞都是正确的。
And I use boost Lambda too for all the implementation because a lot of the stuff, so you think about like, so zip iterator is like a tuple of iterators. And every tuple operator, every like iterator operation is an operation on like through this tuple, right? So it's either like a tuple transform or like a tuple for each or something. And all the functions that you want to do are like trivial so like dereferencing zip iterator is like dereferencing all the underlying iterators of of the stuff into to a tuple transform so with boost lambda 2 how do you how do you write the function that is dereferencing the first argument well it's star underscore one yeah uh how do you
And I use boost Lambda too for all the implementation because a lot of the stuff, so you think about like, so zip iterator is like a tuple of iterators. And every tuple operator, every like iterator operation is an operation on like through this tuple, right? So it's either like a tuple transform or like a tuple for each or something. And all the functions that you want to do are like trivial so like dereferencing zip iterator is like dereferencing all the underlying iterators of of the stuff into to a tuple transform so with boost lambda 2 how do you how do you write the function that is dereferencing the first argument well it's star underscore one yeah uh how do you|||我将 boost Lambda 2 用于所有实现，因为很多东西——所以你想想，比如 zip 迭代器就像是一个迭代器的元组。每个元组操作，每个像迭代器操作这样的东西，都是通过这个元组进行的操作，对吧？所以它要么像 tuple transform，要么像 tuple for each 或类似的东西。而你想做的所有函数都非常琐碎（trivial），所以解引用 zip iterator 就像是将所有底层迭代器解引用并转换为 tuple transform。所以在 boost lambda 2 中，你怎么——你怎么编写解引用第一个参数的函数呢？嗯，就是 * _1。是的，呃，你怎么……
write that as a lambda well it's like open bracket close bracket open paren auto ref space it close paren arrow decal type auto open brace return star it semicolon close brace so it's like it's something like 30 characters to three is is what the difference is yeah um this kind of placeholder stuff, if we can have it in Lambdas directly, would be super useful. So once you start dealing with placeholders in pipeline, well, that lends itself to like,
write that as a lambda well it's like open bracket, close bracket, open paren, auto, ref, space, it, close paren, arrow, decl type auto, open brace, return, start it, semicolon, close brace. So it's like it's something like 30 characters to three is what the difference is. Yeah, um this kind of placeholder stuff, if we can have it in Lambdas directly, would be super useful. Once you start dealing with placeholders in pipeline, well, that lends itself to like,|||把它写成一个 lambda 呢？嗯，就像是方括号、小括号、auto、ref、空格、it、小括号、箭头、decltype auto、大括号、return、解引用 it、分号、大括号。所以这就像是大概 30 个字符对 3 个字符的区别。是的，呃，这种占位符的东西，如果我们可以直接在 Lambda 中使用，将会超级有用。一旦你开始处理管道中的占位符，嗯，这就自然而然地引出了……
well, what if you use that same technology to actually construct a Lambda directly? Like what if we had a new kind of Lambdas that was just based on placeholders? And so there's a whole section in the paper of what kind of exploring what that means, like what kind of syntax could we use and how do we like differentiate it from the languages that we have today and how do those apply? So if we had that new sort of syntax, would you then, instead of having placeholders directly
well, what if you use that same technology to actually construct a Lambda directly? Like what if we had a new kind of Lambdas that was just based on placeholders? And so there's a whole section in the paper of what kind of exploring what that means, like what kind of syntax could we use and how do we like differentiate it from the languages that we have today and how do those apply? So if we had that new sort of syntax, would you then, instead of having placeholders directly|||嗯，如果你使用相同的技术来直接构造一个 Lambda 会怎么样？比如，如果我们有一种完全基于占位符的新型 Lambda 会怎么样？所以在论文中有一个整节，探讨了这意味着什么，比如我们可以使用什么样的语法，以及我们如何像将它与我们今天的语言区分开来并如何应用它们？所以如果我们有那种新语法，你会不会——而不是直接在……
in the piping operator, would it just be that you just say that the right-hand side is a function object and then just the convention would be that people would use the super-abbreviated lambda syntax to write them? Or would you still want the placeholders directly in the piping syntax? I think you'd still want the placeholders directly because there's a few significant differences in why you wouldn't want it to just be a function call. One is, for lambdas, we'd still need capture because even with the placeholder case,
in the piping operator, would it just be that you just say that the right-hand side is a function object and then just the convention would be that people would use the super-abbreviated lambda syntax to write them? Or would you still want the placeholders directly in the piping syntax? I think you'd still want the placeholders directly because there's a few significant differences in why you wouldn't want it to just be a function call. One is, for lambdas, we'd still need capture because even with the placeholder case,|||管道操作符中使用占位符，而只是说右侧是一个函数对象，然后惯例将是人们会使用超级简写的 lambda 语法来编写它们？或者你仍然希望占位符直接出现在管道语法中？我想你仍然会希望占位符直接出现，因为为什么你不想让它仅仅是一个函数调用，这其中有几个显着的区别。其一是，对于 lambda，我们仍然需要捕获（capture），因为即使在占位符的情况下，
we're still C++ and we don't want to do either. You wouldn't want to pick an implicit capture, so you'd want to make it explicit for one reason or another. But then it's not really a function call because if we know we're piping, we know we're evaluating this directly. So we don't want to introduce another scope, which is particularly important because one of the things, once you get into placeholder land, you can put an arbitrary expression on the right-hand side of pipe. We just give pipeline extremely low precedence, and then you could do things like, you know,
we're still C++ and we don't want to do either. You wouldn't want to pick an implicit capture, so you'd want to make it explicit for one reason or another. But then it's not really a function call because if we know we're piping, we know we're evaluating this directly. So we don't want to introduce another scope, which is particularly important because one of the things, once you get into placeholder land, you can put an arbitrary expression on the right-hand side of pipe. We just give pipeline extremely low precedence, and then you could do things like, you know,|||我们仍然是 C++，我们不想两者都不做。你不会想选择隐式捕获，所以出于这样或那样的原因，你会希望它是显式的。但它并不是真正的函数调用，因为如果我们知道我们在进行管道传输，我们就知道我们正在直接对其求值。所以我们不想引入另一个作用域，这特别重要，因为其中一件事是，一旦你进入了占位符的世界，你可以在 pipe 的右侧放置一个任意表达式。我们只是赋予 pipeline 极低的优先级，然后你就可以做一些事情，比如，你知道的……
maybe the motivating use case is doing like F of placeholder, but you can also do F plus placeholder, F times placeholder, right? You can use placeholder as like a substitute for parentheses. But importantly, one of the things you can do is co-weight placeholder, co-yield placeholder. And so like if you want to do the coroutine operations, then you can't make it a function
maybe the motivating use case is doing like F of placeholder, but you can also do F plus placeholder, F times placeholder, right? You can use placeholder as like a substitute for parentheses. But importantly, one of the things you can do is co-weight placeholder, co-yield placeholder. And so like if you want to do the coroutine operations, then you can't make it a function|||也许驱动用例是做类似 F(placeholder) 的事情，但你也可以做 F + placeholder、F * placeholder，对吧？你可以把占位符当作括号的替代品。但重要的是，你可以做的一件事是 co_await placeholder、co_yield placeholder。所以如果你想做协程操作，那么你就不能把它做成一个函数……
because you can't introduce that other function scope because then you break coroutineness. Yeah, that's a good point. Which is actually one of the places where this whole what if we think about it as a language bind kind of model kind of breaks down because if you want to support co-weight, which I think makes perfect sense to support, that doesn't really work by thinking about it as a function.
because you can't introduce that other function scope because then you break coroutineness. Yeah, that's a good point. Which is actually one of the places where this whole what if we think about it as a language bind kind of model kind of breaks down because if you want to support co-weight, which I think makes perfect sense to support, that doesn't really work by thinking about it as a function.|||因为你不能引入那个其他的函数作用域，否则你就会破坏协程性。是的，这是一个很好的观点。这实际上是整个“如果我们把它当作语言 bind 类型的模型会怎样”的想法破产的地方之一，因为如果你想支持 co_await（我认为支持它是完全合理的），如果把它当作一个函数来考虑，那是行不通的。
So it's like, I don't know, it's kind of like a weird thing. One of the things to ask you, and actually you might not know the answer to this question. I think you and I, well, at the end of the paper, you sort of articulate between the design choices, what you're, what you are in favor of and pipeline plus placeholder is definitely something you want, which is definitely something I want as well. Not just for the fact that there are a number of range adapters that I mentioned before that don't work with the pipe operator and the fact that they don't work with the algorithms in those, you know, std colon colon ranges namespace.
So it's like, I don't know, it's kind of like a weird thing. One of the things to ask you, and actually you might not know the answer to this question. I think you and I, well, at the end of the paper, you sort of articulate between the design choices, what you're, what you are in favor of and pipeline plus placeholder is definitely something you want, which is definitely something I want as well. Not just for the fact that there are a number of range adapters that I mentioned before that don't work with the pipe operator and the fact that they don't work with the algorithms in those, you know, std colon colon ranges namespace.|||所以这就好像，我不知道，这有点像一件奇怪的事情。要问你的一件事是，实际上你可能不知道这个问题的答案。我想你和我——嗯，在论文的末尾，你阐述了各种设计选择，你倾向于什么，而 pipeline 加占位符绝对是你想要的，这绝对也是我想要的。不仅仅是因为我前面提到的一些范围适配器不能与管道操作符一起工作，以及它们不能与那些——你知道的，std::ranges 命名空间中的算法一起工作的事实。
It also enables you to do the duplicate things, which is a whole other thing that I like, because you can technically mimic some of the composition patterns that you get from combinatory logic, which is like a big thing that I really like. However, there are some people that are against the placeholder. And I think one time i i tweeted something and then gasper replied gasper asman who is a member of the c++ um committee and he said please no don't put the placeholder uh in and i think i asked why but i don't think he replied
It also enables you to do the duplicate things, which is a whole other thing that I like, because you can technically mimic some of the composition patterns that you get from combinatory logic, which is like a big thing that I really like. However, there are some people that are against the placeholder. And I think one time i i tweeted something and then gasper replied gasper asman who is a member of the c++ um committee and he said please no don't put the placeholder uh in and i think i asked why but i don't think he replied|||它还使你能够做重复的事情，这是我喜欢的另一大块，因为你在技术上可以模仿从组合逻辑（combinatory logic）中获得的某些组合模式，这就像是我非常喜欢的一个大趋势。然而，有一些人反对占位符。我想有一次我发了一条推特，然后 Gasper 回复了——Gasper Asman，他是 C++ 委员会的成员，他说：“求求了，不要把占位符加进去。”我想我问过为什么，但我想他没有回复。
do you know what like the main sort of drawbacks other than, because I know the paper mentions that it's a bit more verbose in the case where you have to, you know, you have a bunch of unary things and yes, having to spell out the unary thing is a little bit uglier. But in my opinion, that's like a weak argument that you're getting something less verbose compared to like giving up the flexibility that you get with the placeholder. Do you know what potentially Gasper and other folks that are against the placeholder, what their motivation for that is? So I think the verbosity is a significant argument against what I hear from people. And it's even something that I've seen multiple people suggest like, okay, well, placeholder, but allow the placeholder to
do you know what like the main sort of drawbacks other than, because I know the paper mentions that it's a bit more verbose in the case where you have to, you know, you have a bunch of unary things and yes, having to spell out the unary thing is a little bit uglier. But in my opinion, that's like a weak argument that you're getting something less verbose compared to like giving up the flexibility that you get with the placeholder. Do you know what potentially Gasper and other folks that are against the placeholder, what their motivation for that is? So I think the verbosity is a significant argument against what I hear from people. And it's even something that I've seen multiple people suggest like, okay, well, placeholder, but allow the placeholder to|||你知道除了——因为我知道论文提到在必须——你知道的，你有一堆一元（unary）事物的情况下它稍微有点冗长，是的，必须拼写出一元的事物有点丑。但在我看来，比起放弃用占位符获得的灵活性，获得更少冗长的东西是一个微不足道的论点。你知道 Gasper 和其他反对占位符的人的动机可能是什么吗？所以我认为冗长是反对人们所听到的一个重要论点。这甚至是我看到多个人建议的事情，比如，好吧，有占位符，但允许占位符……
be optional so that you can pipe to something like f paren paren and have that work as if you had the placeholder. If there's no placeholder, then it has to be a function call and then you stick it into the first argument kind of thing. There are even people that argue against the need for the paren. When we were standardizing ranges two there was a um a point of contention about whether you would need to write like x pipe ranges two with empty parens or not um you know so i i i think that there's there is a great desire for conciseness from certain set of folks. And just to clear up the ambiguity for the listener, this is ranges colon colon T-O, not like a second version of ranges that we're introducing.
是可选的，这样你就可以把它管道传输到类似 f() 的地方，让它就像你有占位符一样工作。如果没有占位符，那么它必须是一个函数调用，然后你把它塞进第一个参数那种。甚至有人反对需要括号。当我们标准化 ranges v2 时，有一个……关于是否需要像 x | ranges::to<> 这样带空括号来写的争论……你知道的，所以我认为某些人对简洁有着极大的渴望。为了给听众消除歧义，这是 ranges::to，而不是我们引入的 ranges 的第二个版本。
Yes, yes. It's hard to speak above that one function. Or maybe a simpler way to explain that is like there are some people that if you have like X pipe F empty parens, some would argue that it'd be more elegant to have just X pipe F. It's definitely more elegant, but like, you know, the language that Barry just spelled out, our lambda,
是的，是的。超越那个函数很难表达。或者用更简单的方式来解释，就是有些人如果你有像 x | f() 这样，有些人会争辩说只有 x | f 会更优雅。它绝对更优雅，但是像 Barry 刚才阐述的那种语言，我们的 lambda，
is like, you know. Yeah, we're not an elegant language in many ways. So yeah, so the two, I think there are actually slightly different arguments. The argument for two, I think they're actually slightly different arguments. So the argument for two, I think, is a little bit different in that if you look at all of our unary adapters,
就像是，你知道的。是的，我们在很多方面都不是一个优雅的语言。所以，是的，这两点，我认为其实是略有不同的论点。我认为关于第二点的论点其实是略有不同的。所以关于第二点的论点，我认为有点不同，如果你看看我们所有的单一参数适配器，
you don't have to put parens for any of them, right? So if you pipe to views reverse or views join, you can put the parens, but you don't have to. They work without it. And in fact, I'd never see anyone write parens.
你不需要为它们中的任何一个加括号，对吧？所以如果你管道传输到 views::reverse 或 views::join，你可以加括号，但你不需要。它们没有括号也能工作。事实上，我从没见过任何人写括号。
And so that works. And so in that sense, if you think about, like, 2TO, like, stood vector, close bracket, that is unary, right? Like, I'm just piping a range and I'm converting it directly to a vector. So why is that the one unary adapter that I have to put parens in? It can take other arguments, but I think the overwhelmingly common use case will be that it won't take any. is that we're not even sure if the core language blesses the implementation and approach to getting rid of the parens. Like if that is actually valid per the language. So it's not even like this is like a structural design reason why the parens
所以那是行得通的。所以从这个意义上讲，如果你考虑像 std::vector 这样的 ranges::to，那是单一参数的，对吧？就像，我只是在管道传输一个范围，并把它直接转换为一个 vector。那为什么那是唯一一个我必须加括号的单一参数适配器呢？它虽然可以接受其他参数，但我认为绝大多数常见用例是它不需要任何参数。……是我们甚至不确定核心语言是否支持这种摆脱括号的实现和方法。就像这在语言中是否真的有效一样。所以这甚至不是说括号有什么结构上的设计原因
are super important. We're just like not sure if it's actually legit. But the other, for Pipeline specifically, so this is what I find interesting, is that there's a JavaScript proposal for the Pipeline operator. And I link to it in all the papers. And there's been a lot of discussion on there over the years about various designs.
超级重要。我们只是……不太确定它是否真的合法。但是对于 Pipeline 来说，这就是我发现有趣的地方，有一个关于 Pipeline 运算符的 JavaScript 提案。我在所有的论文中都链接了它。多年来，关于各种设计，上面有很多讨论。
And they've gone through the same kinds of, well, there's three or four different models for Pipeline, which is the right one. about various designs and they're they've going through like the same kinds of like well like there's like three or four different models for pipeline which is the right one and they've also um seriously considered this like um use a placeholder but like make it optional and what does it mean for not having a placeholder um and one of the issues that like the optionality does add complexity to the design right because you have to determine what that means. And in particular, like if you want x pipe f to automatically mean f of x, but you also want x pipe to f open paren, like close paren to mean f of x.
他们经历了同样类型的……好吧，有三到四种不同的 Pipeline 模型，哪个才是正确的。关于各种设计，他们经历了同样类型的……好吧，有三到四种不同的 Pipeline 模型，哪个才是正确的，并且他们也……认真考虑过这种……使用占位符，但让它变成可选的，如果没有占位符意味着什么……可选性确实给设计增加了复杂性，对吧？因为你必须确定这意味着什么。特别是，如果你想让 x | f 自动意味着 f(x)，但你也想让 x | f() 意味着 f(x)。
How do you like, so does no placeholder mean you call the right hand side or does no placeholder mean you insert into the right hand side? Do we have different rules for f versus F, paren, paren? This adds complexity. There's also discussion there about, and some of it was more specific to JavaScript, like we wouldn't have this problem. But how do you know that the user intended to do this or not
你该怎么做，那么没有占位符意味着你调用右侧，还是没有占位符意味着你把它插入右侧？我们对 f 与 f() 有不同的规则吗？这增加了复杂性。那里也讨论了……其中一些更针对 JavaScript，就像我们不会遇到这个问题一样。但你如何知道用户是故意这样做的还是无意的，
becomes more of an issue? And the way that they're leading is mandatory placeholder. Because placeholder itself, once you have placeholder at all, that's complexity, right? Because the simplest version that was like the R0 version that we proposed, where the right-hand side has to be call expression, and then you just stick it into the left-hand side, that's a fairly simple thing to explain explain and it's a fairly simple thing to implement um and i can even i can say that because like i implemented this in clang and it did not take me very long um and like it was probably not the right way to implement it in clang like i didn't
这变得更成问题了。他们倾向的做法是强制使用占位符。因为占位符本身，一旦你有了占位符，那就是复杂性，对吧？因为最简单的版本，就像我们提议的 R0 版本，其中右侧必须是一个调用表达式，然后你只需把它塞进左侧，这是一个相当简单的东西可以解释，也是一个相当简单的事情去实现……我甚至可以说，因为我在 Clang 中实现了这一点，并且没花我太长时间……就像它可能不是在 Clang 中实现它的正确方式……我没有
like create a new ast node i just kind of hacked it into like the regular function call node um but it it's like a very simple thing to implement versus placeholder is much more complicated. And you have to deal with like, well, what things can you place hold into and not? And can you use it more than one time? And like, what about lambdas? But it lets you do so many more things and it adds a lot more explicitness to it. And so I'm not sure in the grand scheme of things that saving one to three characters per expression ends up being a make or break kind of thing. Yeah, I kind of, I think I agree with you. And I think that there's a, if we're going to do a language, if we're going to add new language support for a pipeline operator, surely one of the rationales and motivations for that is to enable pipelining of things that we can't do today. And I think a lot of those cases, a lot of those more interesting cases,
创建一个新的 AST 节点，我只是把它硬编码到常规的函数调用节点中……但它是一个非常简单的实现，相比之下，占位符要复杂得多。你必须处理诸如：你可以把占位符放到什么东西里，什么东西不行？你能使用它不止一次吗？还有 lambda 怎么样？但它能让你做更多的事情，并且它为它增加了很高的明确性。因此，在宏大的计划中，每个表达式节省一到三个字符最终是否是一个决定成败的事情，我并不确定。是的，我有点……我想我同意你的看法。而且我认为，如果我们要搞一门语言，如果我们要在语言中为管道运算符添加新支持，那么其理由和动机之一肯定是为了能够对我们今天无法做到事情进行管道化。我想其中许多情况，许多更有趣的情况，
like ones that Connor and I have talked about in this podcast before, would really benefit from having the placeholders. So if we're going to go through the trouble of adding language support, I think we would lose a ton of utility if we don't have placeholders. And a world with optional placeholders would mean, you know, you essentially have two syntaxes,
就像康纳和我以前在这个播客中讨论过的那样，如果能有占位符，将会真正受益。因此，如果我们打算费力地添加语言支持，我认为如果我们没有占位符，我们将失去大量的实用性。而一个带有可选占位符的世界将意味着，你知道的，你本质上有两种语法，
and there would be a lot of potential ambiguities, and there'd be more things for people to have to learn. And I don't mean, like, language ambiguities. I mean, just, like, you look at the code, and you're like, huh, what does this mean? Like, mental ambiguities. I mean, just like you look at the code and you're like, huh, what does this mean? Like mental ambiguities. And I don't think that the additional, you know, a couple of characters you have to type is that bad. And I also think, honestly, that it'll be a lot more teachable. You know, when you explain like the pipe piping to people today, you usually tell them it's like Unix, you know, like shells, it sort of works like this. And that's like a good
并且会有很多潜在的歧义，人们需要学习的东西也会更多。我指的不是语言歧义。我的意思是，就像你看这段代码，然后你会想：嗯，这是什么意思？就像心理上的歧义。我的意思是，就像你看这段代码，然后你会想：嗯，这是什么意思？就像心理上的歧义。而且我不认为你必须额外输入的这几个字符有那么糟糕。老实说，我也认为它会更容易教授。你知道，当你今天向人们解释管道时，你通常会告诉他们它就像 Unix，你知道的，就像 shell 一样，它大概是这样工作的。这就像是一个很好的
analogy, but that sort of assumes that the way that like a Unix shell pipeline works is like this intuitive thing. And it is an intuitive thing because we all know it, but I think it's not necessarily natural. If you just look at some of these examples in the paper with the placeholder syntax, I think if you showed somebody who had knowledge of C++ but had no knowledge of the pipe operator and no knowledge of ranges piping and no knowledge of unique shells,
类比，但这在某种程度上假设了 Unix shell 管道的工作方式是一种直观的东西。它确实是一种直观的东西，因为我们都知道它，但我认为它不一定是自然的。如果你只是看一下论文中带有占位符语法的一些例子，我想如果你向一个懂 C++ 但不懂管道运算符、不懂 ranges 管道、不懂 Unix shell 的人展示这些，
I think that they would look at that and they'd probably understand what it meant. Yeah. All right, chip it. C++26. So what do you think the odds are, Barry? I don't know. You don't put bets on your own papers? I don't. Well, also, because I don't even know what the bets on your own papers i don't um well like also because like i
我想他们看一眼就能大概明白是什么意思。好的，那就发布吧。C++26。所以你觉得几率有多大，Barry？我不知道。你不对你自己的论文下注吗？我没有。嗯，还有，因为我甚至不知道我自己的论文……我不知道……嗯，就像也是因为……
don't even know what the right answer to any of these questions is so uh i mean i don't i know what some of the wrong answers are like there's a pipeline model where you just where the right hand side just invokes you treat the right hand side as a function and you invoke with the left hand side which is like the f sharp model um that's definitely the wrong model for c++ because that doesn't help us at all it just like makes everything more verbose. So I know some wrong answers, but I don't know what the right approach is. That is the inverted invocation in the paper. So that works very well for languages like F sharp that have a lot of other language support for currying and partial function application. We don't have any of those things. And without those
我甚至不知道这些问题的正确答案是什么，所以……我的意思是，我不知道某些错误的答案是什么，就像有一种管道模型，你只是……右侧只是调用，你把右侧当作一个函数，并用左侧调用，这就像 F# 模型……这绝对是 C++ 的错误模型，因为这根本帮不到我们，它只是让一切变得更冗长。所以我知道一些错误的答案，但林不知道正确的方法是什么。那是论文中的倒置调用。所以这对于像 F# 这样在柯里化和偏函数应用方面有大量其他语言支持的语言来说效果非常好。我们没有任何这些东西。而没有这些
things, that model just doesn't make any sense. Yeah. That's something that I think about when you're talking about the elegance or the lack thereof in C++ is that for languages that function invocation typically requires parentheses, you end up in a completely different space than when you're you know comparing it to a language like haskell or f sharp because those languages one are functional at their core and two the it's just completely different like the way that you do uh you know quote unquote piping in haskell like it's completely designed around the fact that those languages you know have like you said partial application and currying, and you can do like things super nicely, like flip,
东西，那个模型就完全说不通了。是的。当你在谈论 C++ 中的优雅或缺乏优雅时，我想到的一件事是，对于函数调用通常需要括号的语言，你最终会进入一个完全不同的空间，而当你把它与 Haskell 或 F# 这样的语言进行比较时，因为这些语言一、其核心是函数式的，二、它是完全不同的，就像你在 Haskell 中做所谓的“管道”的方式一样……它完全围绕着这样一个事实设计，即这些语言，如你所说，具有偏应用和柯里化，并且你可以做得非常好，比如 flip，
and it's just, you know, flip and insert that in front of a function. And you've, you've swapped the order that you pass arguments in order to do that in C++, you know, you're calling a template metaprogramming function and boost on a, that, you know, does the same thing, but it's, it's nowhere as easy as just putting a function in front of your other function. And, you know, it's just a different, you know, there's a part of me that's like, oh yes, I want this beautiful, elegant model, but like, we're not Haskell. We're not F sharp. We can't get that. And yeah, you have to, at least for me, I put my elegance like heart on the shelf and say, we're in C++ land. Let's just get the flexible thing and sort of live with it.
它只是，你知道的，flip 并把它插入到函数前面。然后你……你交换了传递参数的顺序以在 C++ 中做到这一点，你知道的，你正在调用一个模板元编程函数和一个 boost 库中的函数，你知道的，它做同样的事情，但它绝对没有在你的其他函数前面放一个函数那么容易。而且，你知道的，这是一个不同的……你知道的，我内心有一部分会想：哦，是的，我想要这个美丽、优雅的模型，但是……我们不是 Haskell。我们不是 F#。我们得不到那个。所以是的，你必须……至少对我来说，我把追求优雅的心放在一边，说：我们在 C++ 的土地上。让我们只管拿到灵活的东西并凑合着过吧。
So I think there's another potentially big advantage to language support for a pipeline operator that we've maybe not talked about before, which is ranges piping is cool and all, but there's a lot of library machinery uh you need to do to make it work and um uh there's this sender's proposal which is a proposal for you know this asynchronous programming framework for c++ which also has used the you know piping uh syntax um and also has a lot of language, a lot of library machinery to support that. And I think that having this in the language would maybe not drastically reduce the inherent complexity of these big library proposals, but I think it would decrease the complexity somewhat.
所以我想语言对管道运算符的支持还有另一个潜在的巨大优势，我们之前可能没有谈过，那就是 ranges 管道虽然很酷，但你需要做很多库机制才能让它工作，而且……有这个 sender 提案，它是 C++ 的这个异步编程框架的提案，它也使用了……管道语法……并且也有很多语言、很多库机制来支持这一点。我认为在语言中加入这个可能不会从根本上减少这些大型库提案固有的复杂性，但我认为它会在一定程度上降低复杂性。
And that I think is a worthy thing to do. Yeah. Yeah. I would say, I guess, as far as like odds go, it really depends on, cause there, there are people that think that placeholders are obviously the correct design and, and the design without placeholders is totally unpalatable. And then there are people that think that placeholders are bad because they add complexity and they add verbosity to what will be the overwhelmingly common use case where you want to pipe into a function call and you want to pipe into the first parameter. And so I think it largely depends on what the relative sizes of those two groups end up being. And just to some degree, the existing piping that we have in ranges, it's not like we're just going to get rid of that. So the people who don't want placeholders or who want placeholders to be optional, then
我认为这是一件值得去做的事情。是的。是的。我想我会说，就几率而言，这 realmente 取决于，因为有些人认为占位符显然是正确的设计，而没有占位符的设计是完全不可接受的。然后还有人认为占位符很糟糕，因为它们增加了复杂性，并且对于绝大多数常见用例（即你想管道传输到一个函数调用中，并且你想管道传输到第一个参数中）增加了冗长性。所以我认为这在很大程度上取决于这两群人最终的相对规模。而且在某种程度上，我们 ranges 中现有的管道，并不是说我们就会直接摆脱它。所以那些不想要占位符或者希望占位符是可选的人，那么
that syntax, at least for ranges, is going to be there forever. Yeah, we can't really get rid of it. Yeah. All right, well, we're, I think, roughly 45 minutes into this, and that's about the halfway mark. I have no idea how I'm going to cut this up, but before we move on to the next paper,
那种语法，至少对于 ranges 来说，将永远存在。是的，我们真的摆脱不了它。好的，我们差不多进行了 45 分钟，大约是过半的标志了。我不知道我将如何剪辑这个，但在我们转向下一篇论文之前，
and maybe we'll turn this into like a mini Rust episode because we're in our Rust phase of our podcast. We've temporarily turned into a Rust podcast, kind of. Stay tuned to hear Barry's thoughts on the Rust programming language in part two of this two part interview. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也许我们会把这个变成一个类似 Rust 的迷你剧集，因为我们正处于播客的 Rust 阶段。我们暂时变成了一个 Rust 播客，某种程度上。请继续收听，听听 Barry 在这篇分为两部分的采访的第二部分中对 Rust 编程语言的想法。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，并祝你有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。